Volumetric Fog is an optional part of the Exponential Height Fog actor.
Volumetric Fog computes participating media density and lighting at every point in the camera frustum to support varying densities and any number of lights that affect the fog.
When working with Volumetric Fog, it's important to keep in mind that while you can increase the visual fidelity of the fog, you should be mindful of the associated performance costs.
In some situations, the trade-off for higher visual quality is at the cost of performance, such as LED walls used in virtual production.
In just a second, we'll create a Volumetric Fog actor and adjust its properties.
But first I want to make note of how you can individually manipulate other actors, such as spotlights, point lights, etc.
Their contributions to the Volumetric Fog.
Typically, you'll have a parameter called Volumetric Scattering Intensity.
While the default value of 1 is usually sufficient, there are situations where you may want more or less of the effect in your scene.
Simply adjust this value as you see fit.
Let's jump over to our project, and within our Content Browser, in our Maps folder, we're going to open up the Lit Atmos in class.
So if I switch to Lit mode, you'll see that we have a few of our actors emitting light, but generally speaking, the rest of the scene is unlit.
And that's what we want to start with.
So before we add our Exponential Height Fog actor and enable our Volumetric Fog, we need to add some lights to our scene.
I'm going to go up to Window and open our Environment Light Mixer.
Now this is going to be just a really fast way to add all of our core components that would make up our dynamic real-time lighting.
And that's going to be our Skylight, Directional Light, Sky Atmosphere, Volumetric Clouds is optional.
Of course, we're also going to want our Height Fog.
So I'm just going to simply click through each of these, and you'll see that it adds the component to our scene.
Now this is obviously a little blown out, and we'll make just a couple adjustments.
Now if I go over to our Outliner, you'll see that here we have our Directional Light, Exponential Height Fog, Sky Atmosphere, Skylight, and Volumetric Clouds.
Now if you want to, I'm just going to select these actors and simply create them in the folder.
Let's call this Environment. There we go.
Now we can go back to our Environment Light Mixer, and you'll see that we have Minimal, Normal, Normal, and Advanced.
All this is going to do is just show different settings.
So Minimal is the typical settings that we will adjust.
Normal shows most of the other parameters that we have here.
And then Normal and Advanced is just going to expand out a few more.
So for this case, we'll just keep it at Minimal. We're not looking for anything super fancy.
In the next video, we'll walk through how to adjust our Volumetric Fog and change the visual properties of it.